on this episode of Imagine a world
you know so many of the world's problems
today seem to be coordination problems
like we're stuck in these kind of arms
races like literal arms races between
different nations and like technology
capability arms races with AI that make
it hard to slow down and be like whoa
whoa whoa we gotta like figure out
alignment before we crank up power on
this so like I'm kind of coming out from
a position of Doubt like I have ideas
that I'm excited about like prediction
markets and Affinity cities but these
things haven't been tried and there's a
lot of Kinks that need to be worked out
part of my excitement about like the
decentralized more like anarchic world
where there's lots of different options
and things coexisting is because that's
a world that's full of experimentation
with different social systems and
institutions
[Music]
a mini series from the future of Life
Institute
this podcast is based on a contest we
ran to gather ideas from around the
world about what a more positive future
might look like in 2045
we hope the diverse ideas you're about
to hear will spark discussions and maybe
even collaborations but you should know
that the ideas in this podcast are not
to be taken as F alignedors positions
and now over to our host Guillaume
reason
[Music]
welcome to the imagine a world podcast
by the future of Life Institute I'm your
host Guillaume reason in this episode
we'll be exploring a world called peace
through prophecy which was a second
place winner of fli's World building
contest
at its core You could argue that this
world is about Community it asks how
technology might bring us closer
together and allow us to reinvent our
social systems many roads are explored a
whole garden of governance systems
bolstered by artificial intelligence and
other Technologies
overall there's a shift towards more
intimate and empowered communities
even the AI systems eventually begin to
see their emotional and creative
potentials realized while progress is
uneven and littered with many very human
setbacks a pretty good case is made for
how everyone's best interests can lead
us to a more positive future
our guests today are holly Oatley and
Jackson Wagner two members of the
three-person team who created this world
their third teammate Diana gervich
created the digital mural accompanying
their submission
Holly Oatley wrote the two short stories
she's a creative writer with an interest
in positivity history fantasy and gay
culture and Jackson Wagner is an
aerospace engineer with an interest in
effective altruism rationalism and
forecasting
hi Holly and Jackson thanks so much for
joining us thank you it's really great
to be here yeah thanks it's great to uh
be on the podcast
um how did how did you two come to work
together on this I mean uh Jackson and I
have been friends for a long time since
College always discussing nerdy stuff
together and yeah Jackson just came to
me with this idea and you know asking if
I want to be part of the contest and I I
took a look at and I I you know I've
always been interested in World building
I have all these ideas sort of kicking
around my head about uh futurism and uh
what you know designing uh my own
bespoke future Society might be like and
uh I decided okay well let's adapt some
of that to this project is that kind of
how you experienced it Jackson yeah
um I mean it was very fun to kind of
like get together with a bunch of
friends and stuff but how I initially
got involved in the future of Life
Institute contest was I was like looking
at the a forum one day and I saw that
future of Elections and made this post
announcing they were doing this cool AI
World building contest about like
optimistic Futures and someone in the
comments was like this is bad what's up
with these like really constraining you
know there were these constraints in
order to kind of ensure that we were
depicting like a you know aspirational
world where like a billion people don't
like die in some kind of nuclear
catastrophe along the way to like the AI
future
um and um and some people in the
comments were like oh it's like so
unrealistic to like have all these
constraints or like the future would
look so incomprehensibly alien as soon
as we get AI that it's like impossible
to tell a story that sounds normal or
something and I thought that sounded
kind of silly like there's definitely a
lot of ways that things could go wrong
but there's also a lot of kind of
comprehensible realistic scenarios that
I think uh could be told so I like got
into an argument in the comments about
how like actually the contest was
reasonable and like it was good and you
know it wasn't like you know misleading
or whatever then after like going back
and forth and writing a couple long
comments I was like all right well like
now I've defended this position for long
enough that I could have just entered
the damn thing you know like you only
have to fill out yay many short answer
questions and stuff yeah so I started
started like that
um but um then it turned out to be more
work than I thought to think about like
all these different um different things
although it was very fun so I figured oh
like you know I couldn't do the art for
myself and I could try and write the
stories but then they would just come
off as like the exact same tone as the
writing for the short answer questions
so I figured I should find some people
and then um just figured yeah I mean I
considered like looking for random folks
on the internet but then I thought like
wait a second like I know some people
who write stories and make art
um
do you want to say something about your
third colleague
um Diana and how they got involved in
this
yeah
um so Diana was a friend of tanina my
wife um and we just were familiar with
um some of her artwork and thought that
it would be really awesome to to have
her contribute to uh to the project so
that we could have some like you know
nice custom art I I forget
um like how exactly the idea for like a
kind of Disney style like big mural of
of everything and like timeline form
came together but uh I don't know it was
really fun to
you know try and do a visual
illustration of like the history of the
world rather than you know just
individual moments yeah it was a very
cool to see you guys going back and
forth and and kind of brainstorming
together and being like what if we do it
like this and what if we put this over
here and incorporating some actual I
think you guys said that they you
incorporate some actual AI designed
imagery into that as well
I think it was all it was like Diana
doing the characters that are in the
image and then um tandina did sort of a
collage of the the sort of background
pictures uh and then they helped weave
that all together I appreciate that the
um on the world build.ai now that's
that's been like filled with we've got
like some extra artwork courtesy of um
some Dolly Generations yeah yeah that
was me super fun yeah wait so you're
saying that your wife actually generated
some of the images for the thing and was
not credited
uh well like it was it was all kind of
like a big I didn't want to submit as
four people because like then that would
I don't know then like I and tandino who
are like basically what you know we're
married and stuff I would have got like
ten thousand dollars instead of five
right very generous of you well shout
out to tandina for her artistic
contributions as well she is the power
behind the throne in a lot of ways nice
I'm curious though like Jackson You're
an aerospace engineer by training and do
coding and Holly you have this history
background how did those perspectives
influence the way that you thought about
this future
I feel like
they have a common origin in the sense
that I'm one of those people who grew up
reading science fiction I've always been
interested in Big Ideas
um and I've always been sort of like
hopeful about and interested in the
long-term future of civilization and
stuff I think a lot of what motivates
some people to get into space projects
like you know engineering rockets and
satellites and stuff is because just in
the broad culture people have this
vision of like space is kind of a
metaphor or a a concrete example of like
what Humanity will do in the future so
there's this kind of attitude you know
like people working at SpaceX trying to
make the Mars Rockets to go and like you
know settle this other planet I have to
imagine they're being driven by this
similar kind of wanting to
think about Humanity's long-term future
and make the future go well I think in
terms of like the Practical details like
I don't know I mean satellite
engineering is uh it's similar to other
sorts of like finicky engineering where
you're just building stuff and dealing
with different constraints maybe there
is some attitude of kind of like
I don't know trying to be realistic in a
certain way that is taught by
engineering but you know that's probably
taught by a lot of different disciplines
including like getting a realistic
picture of History yeah but I think
there's a common origin in terms of just
being excited about the future and
wanting to go well yeah and my yeah my
my experience has been you know studying
history I say I'm a student of history
as well as a teacher of History I really
want to try and understand these past
societies how they worked how sort of
the logistics of everything uh in them
came together the ideas the resources
that they had at their disposal you know
all these sort of Interlocking Systems
and then you know in my writing I kind
of often turn that outward and try and
think about okay you know how to design
a society design of reality and I think
I took a lot of that sort of thinking
about the future as a historian might
possibly even you know in the back of my
head what is a future historian say you
know looking back on our era and what
kind of world uh could be you know
looking back at us so thinking about all
these things and you know turning it to
uh the future instead of the past and uh
it fits well with a lot of my my natural
inclinations and what I like to learn
about and to think about
it's a really cool kind of reversal
there of thinking about Imagining the
future as backwards history right I
think of my story ideas that I haven't
gotten to them yet but some of my uh
story ideas for other like futurist
projects would be you know a future
historian you know analyzing uh the the
early internet age or whatever yeah
I think that could be very fun yeah I've
thought about that too like I mentioned
like a really really far future person
like the only data they have from our
whole era is like one teenager's video
blogs and like what do they make of us
yeah yeah what gets lost what gets saved
and like what are their tropes of like
how they describe Us in the same way
that you know historians have tropes of
describing you know the Roman Empire and
things like that which may or may not be
accurate yeah it would be so fun super
fun
[Music]
this world is jam-packed with innovative
ways of structuring and participating in
societies many of its inhabitants are
deeply engaged with their local
communities and they seem to really
benefit from this
take a few minutes to understand how
Concepts like prediction markets or
Affinity cities might provide people
with this genuine sense of belonging and
influence
so Jackson before we get into some of
the specific Concepts that your
submission explores could you just give
us kind of a 10 000 foot view of the arc
that your world goes through
I think the kind of big picture
structure of our scenario from 2022 to
2045 I tried to uh reflect this in the
artwork that we put together in Diana's
beautiful illustrations so if you're
looking at artwork you can see that our
story has this sort of 3x structure
where at first you have all this kind of
decentralized innovation and different
communities spinning off their own
things different governments trying new
things all kinds of different AI
technology just being developed kind of
all over the place by uh by different
organizations and it's this world of
like kind of Rapid change
um and economic growth and new ideas and
and experimentation and it's kind of
this bewildering almost sort of hard to
control but like seems like things are
going well pace of change and then the
second act is the flash flash War which
is this kind of near-miss conflict
between the US and China where you have
this tense standoff and then you have
these AI systems that you know neither
side fully understands there are just in
charge of like Sensor Fusion and you
know dispatching forces and stuff and
you know because the AI systems are like
not totally understood you can you know
you you end up setting off this like
diplomatic crisis where like both sides
kind of over you know interpret the
aggressive signals of the other and then
they they start moving the forces around
too rapidly based on the AI signals and
you know both sides think they're being
invaded by the other and so then that
acts as a catalyst that is sort of
symbolic of like this totally
decentralized Full Speed Ahead you know
economic growth and Technology
developments you know with no
International coordination over it is
not a model that is going to work long
term because this AI technology is just
too powerful and it can easily kind of
uh go out of control so that acts as a
catalyst that gets people thinking you
know less about competing with each
other and more about like hey we need to
coordinate to deal with this this common
problem and create a solution that's
amenable to you know Humanity overall so
then the middle image in Diana's
painting is an image of the Delia
Accords which is our name for a big kind
of like nuclear non-proliferation-esque
but but much wider in scope kind of
agreement that is signed by all the
countries to coordinate on AI Safety
Research to make sure that we can as we
make these systems more and more
intelligent that we make them aligned to
human values and kind of like
controllable and also on sort of like
suppressing AI technology outside of
this you know to make sure that we buy
enough time for this crucial research to
happen we're kind of going to like
centralize this dangerous technology
just like we did for you know nuclear
weapons and uranium ore and stuff and
also sort of setting some ground rules
for uh you know like making sure that
the International System of Nations
doesn't get too upended or that like
economies don't become like
spectacularly unequal and
um kind of putting a little bit more
human intention onto what before had
been a kind of decentralized path of uh
just like growth and boom and bust and
then after that in our uh in our
painting we're just kind of depicting
this optimistic worlds that's going
forward uh with with more sort of human
control and like participation to create
the kind of world that we want to be in
yeah I want to take a moment to talk
about prediction markets so this is kind
of new to me I've been reading about
them but my understanding is basically
it's a betting system in a way where
people can put their bets on How likely
they think certain outcomes are and if
they're correct about that then they get
money and if they're wrong about it they
lose their money yeah and so this is a
way of betting that is reinforced by
people's interest in not losing money
and it basically sources common
knowledge from a large group of people
about what the future will hold yes
exactly so you might have a prediction
Market about who might win an election
right um and so if right now the market
thinks that um you know this there's
only a 40 chance that like uh one
candidate will win
um but I think oh actually like that
candidate has better odds um you know I
think there's like a 60 chance that
they'll win they know my I might buy
some shares in that candidate which
would also push up the the price a
little bit uh in the market in the hopes
that when they actually do win then the
shares would cash out at like you know
one dollar uh so you know I'd buy them
for the 40 cents and then you know I
have like a 60 chance of getting all
those shares for a dollar when the
election happens yeah well one thing
that's kind of tripping me up when I
think about prediction markets in this
way like if it's about an election then
the ground truth is inherently within
the people's beliefs like if everybody
in in the voting group was on the
prediction market then you would expect
the prediction Market to 100 reflect the
reality of their voting habits and so it
would have all the information but when
you talk about something like an
economic policy for example then what
you're capturing in a prediction Market
seems more like the average belief about
the impact or efficacy of this policy
and like is there really that much
reason to believe that the wisdom of the
crowd will be right about that yeah I
mean well this is where like uh it gets
into a lot of like detailed theorems and
things about market efficiency and staff
so on the one hand it's not just voting
right because like if I don't have much
of a belief or something then I might
not participate in like some election
Market or something versus if I'm like
super nerding out and I've like built
all these computer models and stuff or I
just have like a really really firm
belief then I I might be motivated to
like put in a lot of cash on on one side
um and kind of express my like certainty
or strength of belief yeah things like
that yeah so the prediction markets are
just one element there's there's a a
whole ton of really interesting little
elements that you've written into the
story and all these different
governments and so a couple other things
going on in the US you have these
prediction markets that are helping to
figure out what different policies might
do based on some metrics of what we want
our society to look like we also have
liquid democracy you mentioned where you
can kind of like give your vote to
somebody else and they in turn can give
their vote to someone else so you have
this kind of flow of impact
um based on who you trust or whose
expertise you believe in and then we
have Affinity cities where people are
kind of free to move around and create
their own little communities around
special interests can you say a little
more about that yeah so I don't know if
there's a good name for what I'm
thinking of as the Affinity cities uh
concept there's the idea of Charter
cities
um is is very close to this like um
Prosper Honduras is this kind of like
aspiring City in Honduras that has
gotten special permission from the
Honduran government to sort of
experiment with their own civil law code
so they're still like under the
constitution of Honduras and everything
but they can have their own kind of like
business regulations and their own like
land use so it's kind of like
a policy experiment Zone that goes goes
beyond this the the special economic
zone concept like usually special
economic zones are just like about kind
of boring stuff like tax credits for
late manufacturing Industries and things
but Prosper is aiming to have kind of
its own systems of sort of like
governing system and
um different like citizenship uh rules
and be able to experiment with you know
different kinds of architecture
um and all all different sorts of things
but that's explicitly focused on kind of
legal experimentation and like having a
different regulatory regime that might
be present in other countries versus one
of the things that I think has a lot of
potential is just the possibility for
people to
create basically intentional communities
that have shared cultures or you know
shared goals without needing to like get
their own semi-constitution or anything
um so I see that being very
Democratic in a way because you can sort
of opt into the society instead of like
trying to vote and fight over what your
Society is going to be about
um you know you can kind of go from from
place to place and um find the place
that matches you the best yeah I was
thinking about that I like the idea of
like I also am somebody in like sort of
the early middle of their life who has
some flexibility as to where I am and
looking for places to go people to share
my values and all that but it's funny to
think about like second generation
Affinity City residents like imagine
growing up in like surf Town California
where everything is about surfing and
like you just hate the water
I feel like there could be some
interesting stories there of these these
really strong cultures that you grow up
in and don't necessarily agree with it's
kind of interesting like we could
imagine that you know maybe people have
the opportunity to jump around and find
some sort of Value City that suits them
uh better but then on the other hand you
know you've got family and and various
ties to to whether it's surf town or you
know big business town or maybe it's
some fungus growing town for you know
very exciting place for boys right yeah
yeah exactly so yeah I think you could
do so many stories about like the
culture there and what it means to kind
of craft a culture craft a place around
a particular set of ideals or culture I
think there could potentially be clashes
there but um you know hopefully we can
be optimistic you know people are always
looking for a sense of community and
Community was one of the really big
topics that we thought a lot about
um and today you know people are are
generating uh communities online and in
some ways that's working well and in
some ways people are often saying that
they are feeling dissatisfied or don't
have a sense of community so the hope is
to see places like this and the idea of
other things like these neighborhoods
that people are living in other aspects
here giving people more of a sense of
community
um that's lacking in this world you know
I I turn my feeling of like technology
makes me feel so isolated well what if
it didn't what if it made me feel
connected and able to share my ideas and
be with like-minded people what if that
was the main experience that I was
having of it so that's my kind of you
know hopeful optimistic thing but I
think you could totally explore
um you know the pros and cons of such a
city
laughs
this is definitely something sort of
reading our story it can come off as
maybe like what is everyone like
attending meetings all the time and just
voting and you know like doing community
gardens and stuff I think
part of the story there is that when you
have a world that is like uh much more
fluid and when all the services are like
easier to access like if you know
participating in government stuff was
all like we'd done the kind of like
Estonia things and and digitized a lot
of these processes then maybe it would
become easier to do this kind of citizen
participation and also if you were
living in a world where
like right now our form of or like
representation through government you
know you vote for representatives and
then like maybe they pass laws that you
like maybe they don't and you know
really it all depends on like the median
person who's elected you know but if we
were living in some sort of like super
fluid world of like you're voting on the
kind of value function and then the laws
kind of get changed right away but via
the prediction market system then people
might be much more motivated because
they'd have more voice and like genuine
influence over how their worlds was
going to look like yeah you know they
might participate more yeah there's this
element where you describe people kind
of like doing their work while they're
walking around and having like AR
headsets that are unobtrusive and they
can just kind of interact with computer
systems not sitting at a desk and
focusing but like you know moving
through the world and doing it and I
could even imagine these kind of
governance interactions being more like
talking to your roommate about who takes
out the trash you know like you can have
these kinds of interactions that shape
your environment in helpful ways that
are worth doing even if they might seem
imposing with today's Technologies and
systems yeah or like I don't spend a lot
of time going to community meetings but
I do spend a lot of time like just
randomly talking about you know politics
and stuff like that so that you know
there might be almost more of a blend
into daily life of uh this future kind
of like AI enabled Advanced social
technology yeah and I think the one
phrase that might sum a lot of this up
is like the idea of building things
together whether that's on the small
scale or the large scale but large scale
being these giant uh amazing
construction projects and things like
that but the small scale is you know
people are are building the kinds of
houses that they want to live in they're
building the kinds of neighborhoods
they're building the kinds of weekly
get-togethers and and social connections
that they want to have with each other
and that they feel a lot of you know
agency again in the process you know
they don't feel like the government is
some distant thing out there outside of
them they feel like they are part of the
government they are making those
decisions for their their Community
their neighborhood yeah
[Music]
by the end of this world things are
going pretty well AIS have been
recognized as having some rights and are
generally empowering rather than harming
humans but this outcome was by no means
assured Humanity had to weather sudden
military events like the AI driven flash
crash war and find approaches to Global
coordination in the face of massive
change and uncertainty we had to work
together to navigate these challenges
and ensure a safe path to developing
stable AI systems I wanted to hear more
about how these threats were approached
in this world
well I wanted to zoom out a little bit
and look at the the higher level story
in your world where we have this kind of
pivotal moment that you're calling the
flash crash War
that really changed the way that AI is
treated and the way that different parts
of the international Society kind of
work together on it maybe you could
describe a little bit of that
so the the flash crash war was kind of a
near-miss type scenario where I'm
imagining going from a world of kind of
like decentralized AI technology is
being developed by militaries by private
companies by like you know just all
kinds of different groups
um and we're kind of like racing toward
the brink without that much top-down
control you know it's changing the
balance of different Technologies
including like military technology so
it's like kind of destabilizing the
world you know but then we end up with
this scenario where you kind of just
have
AI sensors that are like misperceiving
the other side like so it's almost like
the two sensor systems that are
constructed by the militaries on each
side of this like tense standoff
situation kind of like get into this
unintentional like the back Loop of like
sort of signaling to each other
um which really is not that different
from what happens oftentimes in like
human-led Wars but you know it could
happen at a faster pace and with less
understanding and that kind of acts as
like a trigger for the world to step
back and be like whoa there's got to be
more coordination over this there's got
to be kind of like International
cooperation against this kind of common
thread of this unstable technology yeah
I sort of uh did the Second Story as
government uh people looking back on
this experience and one of the things I
wanted to stress was you know nobody was
like going in you know Warhawk like oh
we got to get the United States oh we
got to get China it was all something
that was a failure in these systems
causing this kind of feedback loop and I
was thinking a lot about um the Cold War
and I was thinking about you know uh
people like stanislav Petrov who
realized that what they were seeing was
an error and prevented a world nuclear
war I think it's a very similar sort of
thing here that both of these
protagonists of this story were people
who were involved in you know saying
okay let's bring some human double
checking to this let's let cooler heads
prevail and I think in a way it's kind
of like the overall outcome of that is
that cooler heads not only prevailed
that the cooler heads are in charge and
people who are like thinking carefully
about these kinds of risks and how to
guard against this kind of scenario
happening again those are the people who
are making this world as it is and who
are creating all this International
cooperation and unity
yeah I thought a really interesting
thing that you guys pointed out was how
the the Delia Accords and the way
everyone kind of agreed to work together
on this and you know limit progress in a
way that you could imagine would maybe
be hampering to any individual country
that thought they would be on top in the
future it was possible because of the
uncertainty and the fast pace of all
these changes because nobody could look
into the future and tell what their
position would be like Beyond this
transition right like anybody could end
up on top or not on top and so it kind
of allowed this even footing situation
where everyone was like we gotta work
together
whoever is on top can't be too powerful
so let's all agree to some limitations
here there's a philosophical thought
experiment I forget who it was by but
just you know designing the perfect
Society in a way where
um you would not be able to tell you
would be incarnated into that society
and not able to tell you know what
social class you would be what race you
would be what gender you would be so
there would be nobody you know trying to
uh get control of the society and
enriching themselves and that's sort of
imagining a Utopia yeah I feel like it's
a similar kind of concept on a global
scale if no country can predict exactly
where they're going to be or exactly how
this is going to affect them they can
kind of recognize the the need for uh
this Mutual cooperation and and really
trying to get a bigger sense of
perspective on what is possible and
where these changes could potentially
lead everyone and seeing themselves in
as more of a global unit at least in
that sense while doing their own you
know different kinds of experiments with
it yeah
yeah this is the the veil of ignorance
uh idea and you know the real world
never gets the perfect situation where
like everyone's sitting in heaven before
they've been incarnated and they're like
designing the Constitution but there are
sometimes you know there are situations
that are more and less like that right
so like if you had come to me while I
was like still in college and been like
hey Jackson I figured out this great
technology that design
um space satellites really really easily
so like we won't need to employ nearly
as many aerospace engineers and like you
know we'll be able to launch so many
more probes to the planets like college
me would have been like awesome like
this sounds like a huge net Win For
Humanity I don't know we can like give
some you know give some pay some
benefits unemployment insurance all the
aerospace engineers um you know but like
on net like this is this is huge you
know but like currently I'd be like well
um I don't know you know like let's
let's think about this as an aerospace
engineer like I'm gonna petition my
Senators so it's like when it's obvious
who the winners and losers are then even
when something is a net positive people
who are like losing out they're going to
want to fight it and so it's hard to
like you know when everyone can can see
the consequences of a decision and see
how it's all going to turn out then it's
a little bit harder to make just a lot
of General positive sum deals versus
when there's like a lot of uncertainty I
love this veil of ignorance concept
because it's such a nice way to turn
what seems like a really scary situation
where there's so much uncertainty and
fast change and like some people might
end up in much worse situations than
before these changes happen into kind of
a hopeful breeding ground for good
collaboration and like good faith
efforts to make a good future for
everyone it's a really cool yeah kind of
making a common enemy out of our own
ignorance if you want yeah totally
yeah and I think a lot of the things
that we imagined like may go into a kind
of international like coordination on AI
agreement were things that we're trying
to kind of mitigate that uncertainty
right so like maybe AI technology would
make the economy like way way more
unequal and just create this kind of
like Lords and peasants situation where
like the people who are controlling the
technology they can do everything just
accrue all the resources so maybe you
kind of pass you know a sort of
international law that says okay we're
gonna we're gonna mandate that like the
level of inequality in our economies
doesn't exceed a certain amount so that
if it gets bad enough then we'll just
start taxing the top and you know ping
it out to the bottom just to make sure
that like things don't go too crazy or
another one would be kind of on the
international stage like we're gonna
have joint collaboration kind of like
the inspections that people do of
nuclear programs of different countries
but even more closer collaboration like
there's going to be a unified project
we're going to kind of decide you know
as a species how we're going to use AI
rather than racing and like you know if
America against it first then they get
to do an American Singularity and like
if trying to get something to get
Chinese Singularity and so forth you
know nobody uh would you know would want
that yeah and another another tool that
you use in your world to kind of control
things and slow things down is just like
controlling the pipeline of
um like the chips and the other parts of
these Advanced Computing systems that
are necessary to actually develop them
and also kind of having the most
advanced AI systems in these cages of
research Labs which is featured in
Holly's Second Story
um I thought that was a really
interesting story thing too I found
myself thinking about these three like
potentially superhuman AIS that are just
kind of hinted at in that story and what
their experience would be like I mean if
you're making a lab to hold these
potentially dangerous creatures you know
intelligences that you're creating you
probably don't want to let them know
that they're in a lab
you know against their will so then you
start to imagine that you're this you're
this being that's Awakening and in a
world that you slowly maybe realize is
like an invisible cage like I don't know
it's interesting yeah I'd love to hear
some more thoughts like what how that
could go and what those experiences
would be like of those AI yeah I I think
originally you know I was sketching in
my earliest concept sketches for stories
that I might write in this world you
know I was thinking about the ai's
internal experience a lot more and
that's sort of more the the subject of
stories that I'm I'm writing for other
projects is what is the internal
experience of robots it kind of
hearkening back to Asimov and and all of
his great work with robots but I I think
I one one concept I was floating around
is you know maybe looking at an
interview with one of uh maybe not the
super intelligent AIS but like the very
intelligent AIS and I think the idea I
had is that these AIS part of the
alignment problem might be getting them
very interested in ethics and I'm having
the sense of their own responsibility
and what the right thing to do is you
know in as much as their Consciousness
can be described as being like our own
and yeah it's um I think it's a very
uncertain future on a certain level at
the end of the story but sort of like
just as we start doing the deli Accords
and we we went forward with hope that
you know we could get a handle on this
thing and we did you know the hope is
that the super intelligences that are
coming up down the pipeline will be a
positive impact and that you know a lot
of smart people will work together to
figure that out hopefully
um the super intelligences aren't
offended at being sort of Walled off for
a while yeah I almost imagine them as
like children in the process of kind of
growing up and and when they can finally
you know hit their adulthood then
they're ready to take on the world and
to be part of the world and to be
responsible citizens that that vehicle
scenario anyway and hopefully when they
look back they understand why we we
didn't let them play with the nuclear
buttons
we start talking about you know being
nice to the other kids really early on
yeah it's also interesting to me like
even outside of this sort of adversarial
or like caution based approach of just
keeping them safe if everything pans out
really well and these AIS are like
somewhat smarter than us and they're
super aligned they want what's best for
us like they love us they're like our
children in some way what if they can't
fulfill our hopes for them what if
they're just slightly smarter than us
and we're all looking to them they're
like God they have no idea that I don't
know what I'm doing and we want them to
create something even they don't
understand and how are they going to do
that you know there's also an
interesting story there the best case
scenario right right right it's sort of
a leadership position you know people
are are looking to people in positions
of power and you know it's like I want
you to you know protect the country to
solve my you know economic problems to
take care of my crops and meanwhile this
king is just sitting there and it's like
well I can't explain to you all the the
reasons why that will work or I can try
but it might be a little bit hard
um so yeah I don't know I think we we
might undergo some uh difficult
conversations but again I almost feel
like the the parent-child metaphor only
in this case I guess the AI is taking
the role of the parent
um saying you know like okay I I have
more perspective on this than you and
you know here's here's here's how I can
try to help you understand this at the
very least
yeah one thing that's kind of an
assumption in this whole concern about
AI is like taking off too quickly is
that people will will want them to or
like will be okay with handing over
power and one thing I'm curious about is
like could you imagine a world where
that doesn't happen what if we have like
liquid democracy and all these kind of
empowering things that let people make
policy changes and then people look at
AIS and they're like yeah I don't trust
them even if like they're proven to be
accurate you know like the way that a
lot of science is overall today some
people might still turn their backs and
be like I don't want to do that and what
if we use those new forms of democratic
power just kind of shut it all down and
and find ourselves in some kind of dead
end where we no longer progress
technologically one thing I've been
thinking a lot about is like conveying
to people a sense of agency in the
process and that AI as a technology that
can be helpful them and you know it
needs to show its results show that it
is you know worthy of being put in that
position of of being trusted basically
but I think there's you know two
different ways that it can be viewed it
can be viewed as an imposition and I
think think maybe one of the dangers is
things are so government controlled in
our stories that there could be a danger
of seeing it as like an imposition from
the government but ideally what we would
want to have is a sense of empowerment
and that these are tools AI as
prosthetic you know as something that
makes you able to do things that you
couldn't before and so I think there is
a real task to be done you know
conveying this idea of AIS per se
conveying this idea of AI as being
something empowering and something that
is having a positive impact you can have
all sorts of ideas but even if they're
good ideas they might not be conveyed to
people I think you know we had recently
had um the failure or current failure
anyway of Mark Zuckerberg's you know
metaverse
um it seems like it's not really taking
off the way that he wants it to and I
think part of that is you know because
people didn't see or haven't seen yet
that there is something in there that
they might want to find compelling so I
think there is something to be done and
I'm not sure if this is the role of the
government or other institutions or
maybe everybody together to kind of um
you know this has to be in artificial
intelligence that is is you know working
for us and helping us meet our personal
goals you know that can be trusted but
there's a role to be played of sort of
spreading that message and communicating
to people that they can do great things
and and feel empowered by this
technology
[Music]
foreign
governance tools aren't always top of
Mind in science fiction it's pretty easy
to imagine a futuristic gun or high-tech
power plant but what about a
superpowered democracy
in this world social systems are clearly
presented as Technologies and their
development plays a key role in the
storytelling
I wanted to hear about Holly and
Jackson's Inspirations and their
thoughts about why this kind of story
may be somewhat rare in popular
depictions of the future
often when governance are featured in
fiction they're typically like one end
or the other they're like a mostly
dystopian or mostly utopian and your
world really positions government policy
as tools that can be developed by an AI
just like any other technology could and
I'm curious if there are any other
examples that inspired you to think of
it this way or or how you see this kind
of treatment happening in our culture
yeah I mean there's so many I think we
do attend to go to extremes and we tend
to yeah we tend to depict societies that
are very absolutely good or are
absolutely utopian
um I think probably one of my biggest
Inspirations would be the dispossessed
um by Ursula Le Guin the subtitle of it
is an ambiguous Utopia and I like that a
lot because what she did is she
basically proposed to um you know the
anarchist uh somewhat you might say
communistic society that evolves and
emerges after this revolution on this
Moon you know she shows that society and
what I love that she did is she said
okay I'm going to try and create the
Utopia that would be most satisfying to
me and then I'm going to kind of pick it
apart and show you know how there would
be people who are discontented within
this system and you know what are the
sort of limitations of any particular
idea of this Utopia so even in Utopia
there's going to be Logistics there's
going to be challenges along the way to
getting there for the flip side of this
you could think about something like the
series Terra ignata also known as by the
name of the first book to like the
lightning which is this very wild and
bizarre future and maybe sort of
inspired some of the sense of you know
outlandishness that I've been trying to
cultivate and in that Society is kind of
like a development of all the um
Affinity cities that Jackson's been
talking about you know you have these
giant cultures that anyone can join
around the world and they have been come
completely unmoorged from geography and
they have different principles for
instance you know you can have one
that's like absolute authoritarian
except that you can leave at any time
and then you have another one which is
fun right and then you have another one
that's like um about like cultivating
Human Excellence and you have another
one that's like caring and then you have
one that's basically you know structured
like a business and you have all these
beautiful systems and then we slowly see
over the course of the these novels how
this system falls apart and it's not
anything that any one person wants every
single person involved wants it to
continue but it's not the individual
people involved it's so much as oh the
systems and that there are these sort of
historical forces at work that are
larger than any one person uh so I guess
that's kind of you know a lot of
different angles on this but in terms of
thinking about Utopia or dystopia I
guess I want to stress that Utopia is
made by people but there's
um you know there is an effort to create
it and there's
it just is like we're trying to solve
problems of government today and the
governments that we do have would be
wildly surprising and outlandish to
people hundreds of years ago you know
we're trying to create the governments
of the future and that takes you know
people collaborating and you know
multiple people working together it's
not just individual efforts
yeah yeah both of the examples you gave
have this kind of pluralism where you
have at least two very different models
of governance that are kind of
coexisting and people might be able to
go back and forth between them and it
strikes me that's kind of one end of a
spectrum of what the future could look
like you could imagine we'd all come
together into some kind of like Global
society that mostly has the same rules
or as in your story we'd have this
continuing diversity of like different
experimental models going alongside each
other do you have any thoughts about
like which of those is most likely in
the long run or which of those will be
more desirable for you
yeah I mean there's definitely um
there's like some aspects of our story
that are that are almost like
totalitarian right like or have these
kind of like Global coordination between
all the governments that are like
suppressing AI technology in order to
develop it safely you know like
controlling the semiconductor Supply
chains and and all these sorts of things
and then other elements that are like
hyper libertarian or like anarchic in
terms of just like having laws get
passed automatically based on what the
markets say will like optimize this
function that's being voted on by all
the citizens um or being able to to
leave and join all these different
communities
um I mean in I I'm not sure
in terms of what's what's likely for for
the future I think one of the
constraints that was like driving a lot
of the story like I mentioned earlier
was trying to imagine the transitional
story of like this seems like a really
difficult challenge how do we get from
here to like a bright future that's also
kind of strong enough and good enough at
like decision making executing on ideas
that we could handle this challenge so I
think a lot of
fictional like examples of different
government systems are almost kind of
portraying like an end state or like you
know they're portraying like an extreme
position versus so one of the stories
that I was inspired by is ueizukowski
has this book inadequate equilibria just
like a basically non-fiction book in
which he kind of just like rages about
the ways that different social
institutions are broken in the real
world and then he also has the setting
um from a a long uh kind of like
internet fiction that I that I haven't
read um but it's called doth Ilan and
this is this kind of like fantasy of a
world in which people were naturally
just like way better at coordination
than they are in our world
um and so they're able to solve a lot of
problems that that we we can't in our
world so for instance like you know in
our world maybe we have too many veto
points around like the kind of
construction of new infrastructure right
because like somebody is in the way of
that and how do we properly compensate
them for the fact that we're going to
change their neighborhood or something
but in the world of daphalon like
everybody would like sign a bunch of
crazy contracts like in the John Rawls
thought experiment you know and then
like it would all go uh according to
plan because everyone is just kind of
like born with like a John Rawls tier
ability to coordinate so I was kind of
inspired by that world because you know
so many of the world's problems today
seem to be coordination problems like
we're stuck in these kind of arms races
like literal arms races between
different nations and like technology
capability arms races with AI that make
it hard to slow down and be like whoa
whoa we gotta like figure out alignment
before we crank up the power on this so
in order to imagine like okay how do we
get from here to like the world of
dahilan like I'm kind of coming out from
a position of Doubt like I have ideas
that I'm excited about like prediction
markets and Affinity cities but these
things haven't been tried and there's a
lot of Kinks that need to be worked out
so part of my excitement about like the
decentralized more like anarchic world
where there's lots of different options
and things coexisting is because that's
a world that's full of experimentation
with different social systems and
institutions both yeah yeah the
diversity of what's going on in your
world is kind of dazzling I mean it's
hard to even touch on all the different
concepts that are playing out at the
same time and I feel like maybe that's
part of the reason it's hard to imagine
stories like this like in popular media
I mean even the dispossessed is like
these two societies that are being you
know weighed against each other and
that's like a whole book about it and I
haven't read uh teric NoDa but it sounds
like there would be a lot a lot of
exposition that needs to be done to
figure out what's going on in all these
different varied worlds yes that is
challenge to like starting it the first
time is you're having so much thrown at
you
um right but it could be an interesting
exploration I think of you know maybe
like you know we have this very diverse
world that's coordinated okay how do we
break a very diverse world that's
coordinated what does it look like when
that kind of system fails when the
coordination system fails you know I
think that's one of the many questions
that that series is exploring that's
very interesting but that story can't be
in the background you know like you
can't have that be the background and
then have like Star Wars on top of it
it's just it's just too much yeah yeah
I really like this concept of using
democracy and different forms of
governance as like tools and
experimenting with them and one example
in the real world that I'm pretty
excited about is in Taiwan are you
familiar with Audrey Tang the digital
minister of Taiwan yeah definitely yeah
so she's doing a bunch of really cool
things just in improving the
transparency and accessibility of the
Taiwanese government empowering people
to make their own like apps to interact
with the government and also working on
social media platforms that will help
people figure out where they have
overlap and Alignment in their positions
on things so this is an example of
somebody who's like really trying this
stuff out and I believe she's actually a
conservative Anarchist she says she
doesn't want states in the future but
like this is this is the best she can do
of like contributing to the empowerment
of all the citizens of Taiwan yeah are
there any other like examples like that
or do you have any thoughts about her
work I'm just curious I I you know I'm
just learning about her just now but I'm
I'm finding her fascinating
um I I'm fascinated particularly by the
fact that you know she's an anarchist
and we're coming in you know way in
favor of State action here but at the
same time we both like have this sense
that these Technologies can be tools to
empower people and to give them a sense
of agency and I think I really love the
the radical transparency idea and the
way that she lives her life according to
transparency because I feel like that
could go a long way you know to helping
people have a sense of agency with AIS
and to having a sense of agency with
governments feeling like more
participants in the process and fitting
more with the ideas that we've been
talking about liquid democracy you know
I I think making people feel like they
are moving and part of the system and
not in an illusory way but like you know
actually giving them a role in moving
and shaping of the world I think that's
just fantastic yeah
yeah I mean I think there's a whole
world of like as you can tell from the
content of my story I think that this
sort of like experimentation with um
with different forms of of government
and institutions is totally underrated
um I I live in Fort Collins Colorado
where I was very happy that our city
recently passed a ranked Choice voting
um which is just you know a slightly
different voting system where I think
New York City and several other Estates
and places have have adopted this or
approval voting which is similar where
you're just able to provide more
information to like the election system
by ranking like what are your favorite
candidates and this has all these kind
of Downstream consequences of like maybe
promoting more moderate consensus
candidates because like if it's
worthwhile to be people's second yeah
you don't have to just pick your
favorite and that's it
yeah yeah I mean that's one that has a
lot of kind of real world implementation
and it's sort of like popular in
spreading these days which is really
great but I think there's like so many
things and and sometimes people can get
into this kind of like end of History
type mode where they're like okay it's
all about defending democracy like we
have we have the final form it's like
first passive post voting and then
there's different houses of Congress you
have a supreme court or something or
maybe a parliament I don't know and um
you know and like we figured it out
these guys in the 1700s they're just
really smart and now we just need to
make sure that we never ever ever
backslide into authoritarianism and I'm
like this I'm like there's two sides of
this you know like what about like
exploring democracy or like going
further in the direction of democracy
um there's just a lot of different ways
to do things like right now our whole
conception of local participation or
like local governments is often based on
like a few people showing up to
in-person meetings and almost kind of
like overruling the vote of the majority
of the people or something if they want
to like stop construct somewhere um and
you know we just chose to create that
system giving like a lot of voice to you
know some people who show up to meetings
um but but we can imagine creating
totally other systems so like one thing
that I'm interested in is this idea of
quadratic funding by um Glenn wheel is
involved in this and also uh vitalik
buteran one of the leading creators of
the ethereum cryptocurrency and this
idea of quadratic funding is um it's
this kind of funding mechanism that's
designed to like normally people don't
have much of an incentive to give to
Charities even local charities that they
themselves benefit from like their
library because there's kind of a free
writer problem and the way that we solve
that now is like we have local
governments everyone is forced to pay
taxes and then uh there's like a council
that decides how the tax money should be
spent in the budget but you could
imagine doing this almost
algorithmically by having this kind of
like everyone pays taxes that goes into
a matching fund and then individual
people make charitable style donations
to local organizations in their
Community like firefighting or police or
you know like landscaping or whatever
then the donations are kind of
multiplied by the matching Fund in a way
that's determined by this like quadratic
algorithm based on how many people have
donated yeah you know it's this is kind
of like technocratic detailed thing but
it's a way of yeah it's just this really
exciting proposal that kind of turns
this seemingly insoluble like kind of
free rider tragedy of the commons
problem into a way to actually encourage
people to like give Community funding to
the things that are actually helping
people the most in their daily lives so
it's sort of making charitable
contributions a little bit more like
voting it's kind of recognizing even
small donations you know they're kind of
a signal to the system of like hey this
this organization has a lot of broad
support it's providing value to a lot of
people versus if you just have one
person giving a ton of money then that
is is not matched as as much by the
system because like well it's probably
just this one person is getting benefit
from it and not the whole Community um
so there's less need for like a
community subsidy of it so it almost has
I mean in a kind of big picture
philosophical sense it's almost similar
to prediction markets because both of
these are kind of
living in this spectrum between like
everyone gets one vote kind of voting
power and a kind of economic world where
it's like well some people care more or
they have more information or they
benefit more from it so they're gonna
spend more and like there's a lot of
situations where you want to use the
information of different people giving
different amounts or carrying different
amounts about different issues but you
don't want to like give all of the power
to that so you kind of want to
interpolate between equal voting power
and these kind of like different waiting
schemes yeah that makes sense
foreign
the process of World building has great
potential to make a positive future feel
more attainable
this can be incredibly powerful whether
you're a creative person looking to
produce Rich works of fiction or have a
more technical focus and are looking to
reach policy makers or the public
I asked Jackson and Holly what kind of
impact they hope their work might have
on the world
so you've created this entire Rich
imagining of what the future could be
what would you most like to see come of
this world being shared with the broader
public
I think I would like to see you know if
people are gonna try and adapt this into
other forms of media or you know kind of
tell their own uh stories or just you
know take away some some ideas from this
like I hope that my story is optimistic
as it is is communicating how I feel
about like the the seriousness of the
challenge of safely developing
artificial intelligence and I try to
like cram in a lot of the things that I
find most inspiring and that like make
me most excited about the future I just
would hope to give people a lot of
different ideas for ways that we might
like improve institutional decision
making so that we can get better at kind
of controlling new technologies and and
making sure that they're deployed for
for the broadest benefit of humanity and
also just some concrete ideas about like
what that control of AI you know might
look like like hopefully we get
alignment right early and we never have
to do a kind of global um sort of like
nuclear non-proliferation program of you
know tracking the semiconductor
production and stuff um but I don't
think it's like hopeless sometimes
people in the kind of effect of altruist
and rationalist world can seem like
we've got to get AI right early because
you know by the time Congress gets
involved we're just screwed
um and I want to be like no there's a
plan B here of um trying to kind of
build a world that's strong enough that
it can you know manage these uh
challenges and I think for me I would
love it if people were to take something
away from this is the idea of you know
creating these communities and that
there can be these opportunities for Joy
opportunities for for like working
together and living together and
creating stuff together there's
opportunities for this very vibrant
exciting world and right now I think
there's a lot of pessimism about
technology maybe just because that's the
way that people have experienced it in
some ways but I feel like we we do have
to think very carefully about what our
goals are and I think that's something
that comes out of these stories as well
is you know we are thinking about like
what Target are we trying to hit of you
know what kind of world are we trying to
to have trying to experience and what
I've sort of discovered in the process
of writing is this vision of a world
where people really have this sense of
passion and enthusiasm and feel like
they have community and they have you
know meaningful fulfilling Rich lives
and I'm starting to think now that there
is a way to get to there that you know
we can have this if we think carefully
about trying to go after it if we don't
just go forward blindly but if we go
forward deliberately and say yeah that's
the target that's our happily ever after
that we want to get to is this really
fun and exciting place to be
yeah that seems to me like a call for
more sociology and psychology and those
kinds of elements of science to be
involved in Imagining the future is that
something that you want to see more of
or are there other types of expertise
you'd want to bring in yes absolutely I
would be delighted to see like
psychologists and and sociologists get
involved you know bring on us Humanities
folks we've we want to help we want to
shape the world shape the future yeah I
would love to see more social sci-fi I
also think that a lot of Science Fiction
by default it tends to have this very
pessimistic take often you end up in
this kind of like Black Mirror style of
Storytelling was like okay let me come
up with a new cool technology and then
let me like imagine some
counter-intuitive like bad results of
that technology and then let me tell a
story about that and I think that
oftentimes pessimistic science fiction
stories I guess like feel pretty
Justified like it feels reasonable
sometimes to feel pessimistic about the
broader world but it doesn't seem that
helpful to just be like warning about
stuff and not trying to like plot out a
positive force like it seems a little
bit more action guiding or like
inspiring to kind of give people
ideas that you know that might work and
try and tell an optimistic story about
directions that we might want to go in
rather than just like how we might kind
of Pachinko around in the in the
landscape of history and I do I do take
a lot of positivity from history in a
weird way in that a lot of people at the
time you see this with like the thinkers
of the uh Enlightenment and uh the
thinkers of the Renaissance that they
had a hard time imagining a positive
future they were really caught up in the
issues of their day and the Renaissance
it was the infighting of the city-states
the plague and the enlightenment it was
the uh endless authoritarianism of the
Kings which seemed like permanently
insurmountable and you know now in this
day and age we've surmounted it and that
was not a perspective that Voltaire
could have had at the time but I think
there's reasons to sort of get outside
our concerns of the moment and and you
know look towards a really big picture
and I think it's it's definitely
possible that new and exciting and
things can unfold even if right now we
find ourselves in the valley of doubt
and and stress yeah it's like our world
today wasn't built by the people who are
like complaining that the Spanish
monarchy was absolute crap like it was
built by the people who you know who are
like thinking about like oh like what if
you had like a Congress and then you had
you know like people who were trying to
trying to find a way forward even uh in
a in what seemed like a good situation
yeah I like that that is really really
uplifting to hear Holly about the
pessimists of the past being somewhat
proven Wrong by Eric level of success
yeah it really is encouraging in a weird
roundabout way of like you know yeah you
didn't see the big picture and and I I
think you know it's it's good to to look
to the long term and and cross our
fingers for the long term and I do feel
like the historical forces that I see
moving the world a lot of them are the
winds of positive change so I I think I
can you know have reason to be
optimistic if not certain definitely
optimistic
nice yeah we've covered a lot of ground
this is a really rich conceptual world
and I'm excited for our listeners to go
and check it out on the website and
learn more you have a lot of nice
hyperlinks in your submission that I
also enjoyed diving into so yeah thanks
so much for chatting about your world
with us oh it's been an absolute
pleasure it's been a great nerding out
and thinking about all the great
possibilities that are possibly going to
come down the pipeline yeah well thanks
so much for having us on the podcast
it's been a super fun conversation
definitely go check out those hyperlinks
and yeah I love what you guys are doing
here in the future of Life Institute
[Music]
our guests today were Holly Oatley and
Jackson Wagner you can see more of
Holly's short fiction including a
novella on Her Tumblr which is called
aspiring key maker
if you'd like to hear more of Jackson's
ideas check out his new blog called Nuka
zarya that's
n-u-k-a-z-a-r-i-a where he offers
insights into new cause areas that might
be worth charitable Investments their
third teammate Diana gervich created the
digital mural accompanying their
submission you can see more of Diana's
work on her Instagram Mr underscore dirt
Lord where she shares her Sunny pensive
gouache paintings and some playful
ceramic works
[Music]
if this podcast has got you thinking
about the future you can find out more
about this world and explore the ideas
contained in the other worlds at
www.worldbuild.ai
we want to hear your thoughts are these
worlds you'd want to live in
if you've enjoyed this episode and would
like to help more people discover and
discuss these ideas you can give us a
rating or leave a comment wherever
you're listening to this podcast you
read all the comments and appreciate
every rating this podcast is produced
and edited by worldview studio and the
future of Life Institute fli is a
non-profit that works to reduce
large-scale risks from transformative
Technologies and promote the development
and use of these Technologies to benefit
all life on Earth we run educational
Outreach and grants programs and
advocate for better policy making in the
United Nations U.S government and
European Union institutions if you're a
Storyteller working on Films or other
creative projects about the future we
can also help you understand the science
and storytelling potential of
transformative Technologies
if you'd like to get in touch with us or
any of the teams featured on the podcast
to collaborate you can email World build
at futureoflife.org a reminder this
podcast explores the ideas created as
part of fli's World building contest and
our hope is that this series Sparks
discussion about the kinds of Futures we
all want
the ideas we discuss here are not to be
taken as fli positions
you can find more about our work at
www.futureoflife.org or subscribe to our
newsletter to get updates on all our
projects
thanks for listening to imagine a world
stay tuned to explore more positive
futures
[Music]